So, one last thing I would like to teach you today
is called template inheritance. Now, we can make this quite complex,
but for our purposes we're just going to do this simple thing
that'll make our templates much easier to use. If you notice on
a web page, let's draw one, most web pages have, you
know, a title and a footer. And then they have some
content in the middle. Now this might be the page slash.
And then you might have another page that looks identical. You know,
maybe this is the slash like about page. It also has a
title. It also has a footer. The same title and the same
footer. And it has some different content. When you're generating HTML, you
don't want to have to generate the, you know, write the same title
and the same footer over and over again. Just like in your
code when you use functions and classes to better organize your code,
so you don't have to write the same piece of code over
and over again. You can organize your templates in the same way,
and that's what I want to talk about right now.
You can use template inheritance. So you can have
one template that includes the header, and the footer.
And then you can have a bunch of sub-templates that
use, that just that redefine the content in the
middle. So here's how we're going to organize our code now.
So here's what we have right now in our
code. We have shopping list ,html and we have fizzbuzz.html.
And these files don't have anything in common and we want to
give, we want to add a little title to this page. We're going to
make each of these inherit from base html. And we're going to make
each of these inherit from base html and base html is going to have
some common html that these two templates will share. to make them
match a little better. And I'll just go ahead and show you an
example of how to do this. So, the first thing I'm going
to do is, I'm going to make a new file called base html.
I'm going to go ahead and put in it things I want
these files to have in common and I'm also going to do
a proper html document this time. I saved it as base
html. Now, remember, html documents start with a doc type and
then we have the html tag and then we have the head.
And within the head we can have the title. And so both our
pages will share this title. Within html we have body. Now, I'm going
to add a new syntax here. Okay, so then we have our, we
have our body, open and close, and then we close our html.
This is the basic structure of an html document. And it's what goes
inside body that makes the page unique. Now we can change our title
too, while we're at it. But let's just worry about the body. In
Jinga, the syntax that we can use will look something
like this. The syntax for creating a block, and a
block is something that'll be shared amongst templates. You just
say squiggle percent block and then you give the block a
name and in this case we are going to call it
content. And then you can say end block and we can
make each of our templates use this block of content.
So let's show how we would use this base html in
shopping list. At the top of shopping list, I'm going to say.
Let's add some code to our body that all of our templates
are going to have in common. I'm going to add a little, a header
across the top. Okay, so I just added a little title that we're
going to put across the top of our page. It's just an H1
and I give it a little bit of extra styling. This is
CSS. We gave it a background color of ddd and a foreground
color of 888. This is just kind of. Gray with slightly darker gray
on top of it. I got rid of it's margin and
I gave it a, a height of 50 pixels. Also, I am
also going to add a little style to the body. This will make
a layout, a little bit nicer, margin 0. Okay. So lets go
ahead and use this template in our shopping list. The syntax
for this is quite simple. All we do is at the top
of our file we say extends dot HTML. This this tells this
template that we're going to be a part of base dot HTML.
Now, let's see what this does in practice. Let's make
sure everything's saved. Nothing here is changed and our main handler
were still rendering shopping with html. Let's go to our front
page. Okay, it's still quite a mess here, let's reload this.
Once I reload we can see that the header that I
wrote is here. The kind of gray on gray background, but
none of our content is here. Let's look at the source
for this. Okay, we basically see, this is our base.html file.
But we're not seeing any of that content. Because that
was in that block content, and we didn't overwrite that. So
let's go ahead and take a look at our templates again.
This is our base html. This is basically what we were
seeing as the source in our browser. But our shopping_list.html hasn't
actually filled in this content yet. And let's see how we
do that. All you do is here you say block content.
And this, this line here, block and then the name content,
matches this line here in base.html. And let me
put a closing one at the bottom, endblock, and we
save this file. And we go back to our
browser. And when I reload this page, we see all
of our stuff down here now. Within our base
html template. And when we view the source, we can
see we have the base html header. Then we can
see we have our form content here in the middle,
and then we can have down here there's, it's hard
to see because of the scrolling, but the end of
the base html template. So that's pretty handy. Right, this
allows us to separate the content of our pages and
the templates for that content from the surrounding content that
all of our other pages might have in common. And
I use this a lot in this in this course.
Especially during the blog and some of the other things.